bitcoin is a new virtual currency system
that's been gathering a lot of attention
recently and I thought I would do a
series of videos where I where I really
dive into the innards of Bitcoin and
explain how it works in detail and my
plan for this first video in this series
is to describe some of those mechanics
at a high level and then what I'll do in
subsequent videos is dive a bit deeper
into all the underlying aspects that I
touched upon within this first video and
my hope is that by the end of this video
series you'll know not only what a
bitcoin is but you'll also understand
the mechanics of how of how transactions
are initiated you'll see how
verification occurs for those
transactions and you'll also learn what
it means for someone to really engage in
a process known as Bitcoin mining that
may be a term that you've heard if you
have had any interest in Bitcoin
recently I do want to point out also
that the Bitcoin scheme is fairly
involved it requires some time to really
cover all the relevant details and to me
the best way to really wrap your head
around the scheme like Bitcoin is to to
really suspend belief for a bit and get
exposed to all these relevant details
now you'll undoubtedly you'll have a lot
of questions along the way but my hope
is that by the end of this video series
all of the relevant stones will have
been overturned then your questions will
have been appropriately answered but it
might take some time to get there okay
and in part that's because I'll try to
describe things in a way that's sensible
and that might involve leaving some
details out until I can explain enough
pieces of the scheme and then adding
those details in as I go along so that
you're not inundated with too many minor
points and nuances along the way but you
get a feel for the overall system as I
go through things so with that let me go
ahead and just dive right in and first
of all I do want to point out that
Bitcoin has been described really as a
decentralized currency because there's
no real central bank or entity that's
involved in in generating or transacting
bitcoins and in fact what happens in the
context of it of a Bitcoin is that all
the transactions really require what's
known as a peer-to-peer network a
network of just individual hosts that
essentially collectively agree on
different aspects of how the protocol
is implemented and used okay and then
bitcoin itself is also referred to
sometimes as a cryptocurrency and by a
cryptocurrency I mean that we use a lot
of cryptographic techniques in order to
facilitate or to really enable Bitcoin
transactions to take place and I'll do
separate videos on some of these
techniques but just take it at face
value right now that it's decentralized
and is a type of cryptocurrency and I
also want to point out that the term
Bitcoin itself can in fact be a bit
confusing and in many ways Bitcoin
transactions don't really resemble
traditional coin transactions so much as
they represent a really entries in some
type of a global ledger and by that I
mean that let's say you have a
transaction taking place in let's say
the transaction is taking place within
or among two parties and we'll call them
Alice and Bob which are traditional
names that are used in many
cryptographic protocols to describe the
the parties involved and imagine that
Alice wants to transfer / really wants
to assign a certain number of bitcoins
that she possesses over to Bob ok and
you can think of this transaction really
as an entry in a ledger of some sort
okay and I also want to point out before
proceeding that even though I I've used
terms like Alice and Bob what I really
mean in the context of Bitcoin is is not
the actual identities in their physical
sense but really that Alice and Bob are
our identities in the Bitcoin system and
these identities are just in actual
implementation or just collections of
numbers that do not have to be tied with
Alice and Bob's real-world identities so
in that capacity you can think of
Bitcoin identity really is effectively
being of being pseudonyms okay rather
than real names and the idea is that
Bitcoin then becomes more of a
pseudonymous protocol where people are
addressed by their pseudonyms and that
provides some level of privacy to users
who want to transact using the Bitcoin
system okay now in a transaction between
Alice and Bob what else will basically
do is specify a few different numbers
just to specify how many bitcoins she
wants to allocate to Bob so let's say
Alice started off with 50 bitcoins of
her own
she might decide that she wants to give
let's say 30 of these bitcoins over to
Bob okay and let's say she wants to have
some number of bitcoins returned back to
her so you have to specify or Alice has
to specify rather how much change she's
going to get so in this case let's say
her change is going to be 18 bitcoins
for herself and the remaining two
bitcoins are going to be a transaction
fee and we'll talk about what a
transaction fee means a little later and
I think I'll also dive into it in future
videos but it's basically an incentive
for other nodes in the Bitcoin network
to help Alice in essentially validating
some of the details of this transaction
for Bob okay now Alice will take these
transaction details and apply what's
known as a digital signature to these
transaction details and the digital
signature is basically the mathematical
analog of a traditional signature it
really binds Alice's identity to the
details of this transaction and by
Alice's identity again I mean her
identity within the the Bitcoin system
and this binding is really done in a
cryptographically strong way okay now
the details of this transaction once it
takes place are going to be broadcast
out so alice is going to take these
transaction details and effectively just
broadcast them out to all the nodes in
the peer-to-peer network that represent
Bitcoin nodes okay now Bob when he
receives information about this
transaction he receives it over the
peer-to-peer network um you'll probably
sandy check some part of the transaction
for example he might check that the
numbers work out correctly that Alice
let's say started off with 50 bitcoins
and is not trying to transfer more than
50 bitcoins to him and and so on and so
forth and he's going to have some
mathematical assurance because of some
of the cryptography involved that some
of these claims are accurate that Alice
let's say has the bitcoins that she's
claimed to possess and that she's
expressed an interest to assign those
bitcoins to him but what he won't know
yet is whether alice has really tried to
transfer those same bitcoins to anyone
else over the course of time or or maybe
just prior to that point and the way
that we handle that situation and by the
way I should point out that this concept
of owl is trying to let's say spend
coins twice in the context of digital
cash and electronic currency systems
this concept is known as as double
spending and it's something you have to
worry about when you have virtual
currencies because it's very easy for
someone to just copy the numbers that
represent this transaction and try to
use them elsewhere okay and the way we
basically handle and reduce the risk of
double spending is through a specific
set of nodes in this peer-to-peer
network who are known as Bitcoin miners
okay so you might have heard this term
Bitcoin miners and the Bitcoin miners
are basically specific individuals so
specific nodes within this peer-to-peer
network and what they basically do is
they take all the transactions that they
CNN remember they're listening to all
these transactions not just Alice and
Bob's but other transactions that are
taking place and you'll take those
transactions and ultimately they will
take those transactions and compile them
into what's known is a transaction block
okay so it's basically a recording of
all the the previously unrecorded
transactions okay so if you think of a
single transaction let's say as a ledger
item you could think of a transaction
block as representing let's say an
entire page in a ledger book okay and
these Bitcoin miners will also include
in this block in addition to all these
unrecorded transactions it will also
include in this block a special
transaction that's meant just for
themselves to basically reward
themselves for the effort of doing this
mining okay now transaction block will
also contain an encoding of the previous
transaction block
okay so there's going to be some level
of continuity and then Bitcoin miners
will also include a specially crafted
sequence of numbers associated with
these transactions in this sequence of
numbers is known as a proof-of-work
okay it's called a proof-of-work because
it's something that's really hard to
generate something that requires a lot
of effort to do and that kind of makes
it hard for just anybody to get involved
with Bitcoin mining willy-nilly but it
requires that they really exhibit or
exert some computational effort
basically in exchange for forgetting
this this extra reward of a payment and
also in exchange for getting this
transaction fee that they're going to be
promised by Alice
to engage in this sort of work okay and
I'll talk about what proof of work
protocols are in a separate video in
more detail now because each transaction
block contains information about
previous transaction really what you end
up having is not just a single block you
ultimately have what you can think of as
a chain of transactions and you can call
us a transaction block chain okay and
the idea is that as soon as a Bitcoin
miner is able to construct a transaction
block chain containing all these
unrecorded transactions and this proof
of work
it'll broadcast the details of that
chain out to all of the nodes all the
peers on that peer-to-peer network for
Bitcoin okay and then once the newly
broadcast chain gets kind of verified
and needs to write properties the nodes
on the network are just going to go
ahead and start using it and they're
gonna start appending new transaction
blocks to that chain okay they're going
to take anything that hasn't yet been
processed and start incorporating it
into the transaction chain that was
broadcast out by the node who came up
with the proof of work correctly
okay now this transaction block chain
really what we're going to be doing in
the context of Bitcoin is the nodes are
only going to consider the transaction
block chain that reflects the greatest
amount of work to generate its contents
and again there is this proof of work
that I mentioned that is used to kind of
determine or identify what the what work
was involved in coming up with this
transaction block chain okay and the one
that's the longest is going to be
considered sacrosanct within the Bitcoin
system and future miners are supposed to
only work off of the chain that is the
most work put into it
now what's remarkable here is that this
whole process is decentralized there was
no bank or no centrally trusted entity
that was actually involved in the
transaction hopefully this first video
gave you a bit of a description of
flavor if you will for the high level
mechanics of the Bitcoin system there
are a lot of stones I have left unturned
and what I'll do in subsequent videos is
start covering those details and I'm
sure you have a lot of questions and
hopefully the the future videos will
help answer some of those questions for
you